[Music]
well my next guest is true hollywood
royalty with a glittering career
spanning seven decades awarded the
damehood by prince charles with services
to her services charity in 2015 and next
week will be part of the dames in jags
procession at the queen's jubilee
pageant i'm thrilled to say dame joan
collins hello how are you i'm great but
i want to congratulate you on having
your own show thank you i think it's
great
it doesn't really feel like my
instructor you're here i feel like
you're anointing me like it's almost
after the queen is the next best thing
to a royal visit oh please come on
now you're part of the danes in jags
what is this the hags in jags
well after they i mean this thing is
going to be so enormous i mean so
fantastic it's going have you ever been
to the um thanksgiving macy's
thanksgiving parade it's going to be
like that they're going to have all
these floats they're going to have um
people dancing and singing and
all kinds of people on it and then we
are coming down in these amazing vintage
jaguars open uh i've got a white one and
twiggy's there
and dame darcy bussell and um i can't
remember who the others are you must
have it written down a
load of great danes well i think so and
then we are going to go around waving
gracefully i hope
to um the populace who are going to line
up and then we're going to go and
hopefully go into one of the boxes and
watch the rest of it but it's very
exciting because i'm such a monarchist
and i'm such a royalist and i love the
queen so much that to have been asked is
a is a great is really you've been in
you've been in movies 70 years the queen
has been on the throne 17 i know it's
quite amazing and there you are together
but
she's a remarkable woman isn't she she
is the most inspirational woman i think
that ever has lived in my lifetime i
don't know i never knew my mother teresa
or joan of arc but i mean they were
probably pretty good but no she is
because she's so
down to earth and gentle and
humorous and
she's got through all of these dreadful
things that have happened to her i mean
there really have been some awful things
that she's had to deal with and she does
it with such grace and the fact that she
has never ever commented on anything
that's going on no interviews nothing
but even an aside because you know there
are people there liberating and they
could say that she said oh i think this
this play is ghastly as we all do when
we go to see something but the last time
i saw her we had it was at buckingham
palace
and we were talking about pygmalion my
fair lady because some students gave um
a performance and she's so knowledgeable
about the theater and we had really very
nice chat no i just love her she's been
a part of my life i kept a scrapbook of
her wedding to
prince philip when i was a a school girl
we were all madly in love with prince
philip at school you know because he was
so good she must really miss philip
don't you think well after what 74 years
of being married yes but look at that
man who just died with a broken heart i
know more that's the story from texas
i mean imagine they've got four children
oh no the teacher had been teaching
there for many years she gets shot dead
by this lunatic and then within 24 hours
her husband literally dies of a broken
heart this was his childhood sweetheart
but those four kids now have no parents
oh my god it's it's heartbreaking it's
beyond terrible what goes on with these
things i don't understand why if
somebody posts pictures of themselves on
social media buying guns talking about
guns saying i want to kill people why
they can't be
by the fbi or the cia or whoever goes
literally put on instagram pictures of
the two ar-15 rifles but here's the
point he was 18 and when he turned 18 a
couple of weeks ago he was legally
allowed to buy these guns he went and
bought his guns he couldn't have bought
a beer that would have been illegal he
couldn't buy a kinder surprise chocolate
egg they're illegal in the whole of
america because the toys may choke you
an 18 year old boy could buy two ar-15
semi-automatic rifles and then go and do
what he did and it's that inconsistency
of the laws which i find so completely
baffling but i always say to people you
and i have worked in america a long time
it's it's embedded in the culture they
have half of the world's guns are in
america in america nearly half of the
population of america own guns so you're
talking about 150 60 million people in a
country who have guns and therefore
support their usage and they believe
passionately that the second amendment
of the u.s constitution entitles them as
ratified by the supreme court to own
firearms well i can understand that you
might want to own a firearm a small
glock or something but to own two
assault rifles or to own machine guns
that's what i don't understand and i
don't believe that 40 percent or
whatever percentage you said of the
population
goes along with that i think that they
want to have a gun and if somebody comes
into their property they can shoot them
but
assault rifles i mean
the last two massacres the one in the
supermarket the white supremacist and
now this one they're both 18 years old
the sandy hook shooter was 20.
what is going on with these young men
that they're so completely detached from
reality and so angry that they want to
go and commit these atrocities well i
had the theory that young people today
are brought up and love
violent um
movies violent uh this one this one
like call of duty they live on them they
they're brought up but from the age of
four or five i think it desensitizes
them of course it does it's like porn
the same thing you desensitize which is
why i think that women are being abused
so much um and i don't understand why
that is allowed because
rosie and i
we watch a lot of television and so many
things we say we can't watch this the
whole
screen is covered in blood you know the
there's 4 000 people being killed and
there's the most awful thing that women
being abused and slapped and hit and
it's just not right it's not what i i
wasn't allowed to see certain movies you
remember they used to have youth
certificate universal yeah i wasn't
allowed to see anything like that and i
think that's probably you know my
generation is mostly i think it's a lot
of things i think the desensitizing is
definitely part of it they all seem to
be into violent video games i think that
they're i think medication americans are
very heavily medicated well it's not
just for americans no but i'm saying i
don't think they have any more of that
than the many countries or indeed more
mental health issues what they do have
is mentally deranged people who can get
very easy legal access to weapons of war
when you see these guns these are like
machine guns machine guns are actually
illegal in america but these are
semi-automatic they can fire a bullet
every time you pull a trigger and
obviously if you're going to buy
something like that you're going to kill
somebody 375 rounds of ammunition and
the guy who's in the shop
has the fbi um
seems completely crazy
well thank god it can't happen in this
country yeah well it happened here in
dunblane in school that was how long ago
1996 and i was actually editing well i
was editing the daily mirror at the time
you see britain wasn't a gun culture
country well very few civilians owned
guns so it was an easier campaign really
we all came together left and right it
wasn't political says to my american
friends i don't know why politics gets
involved with this this is about saving
kids from being shot dead at school but
in a wee campaign we got the laws
changed and we haven't had a school
shooting since america's had 27 school
shootings this year i i can't you know i
mean can you imagine being a mother and
hearing that or even being a mother now
and sending your kids to school and
thinking are they going to be safe
i mean you always thought your children
were going to be safe i actually emailed
a friend of mine is one of the dumb
blame mothers because every time one of
these things happens i just can't
imagine what they go through and i sent
her a name she replied a very nice
heartfelt email but it
always takes them straight back when
they have this
what it does and their kids never grow
up and just what they have to go through
is so unthinkable i think it's i think
the whole thing is unthinkable and i
think the whole thing of somebody
mentally wanting to kill
children babies
which of course is what is going on in
ukraine as well but we don't seem to
talk about that anymore well that's
another thing you know ukraine's
disappearing from the news agenda which
is what vladimir putin wants he's
carrying no he's
he wants us to stop talking about it let
him just carry on seizing the country
it's just appalling which is what he's
doing you know is it true that she's
very ill i keep on hearing these rumors
people say that i mean who the hell
knows all i do know is he is raising
cities to the ground literally
destroying him
yes he is worse than him he's well he's
he's he's up there with him yeah and i
think his aspiration is to seize ukraine
and then to try and seize other
countries of course
stop finland yeah norway what do you
make of party gate boris johnson you
know boris johnson you've been at
parties with bernie sanders he was my
boss once when he was at the state
senate and he was this spectator yeah
um what do i think of it i have to say i
haven't really
gotten involved in it totally but i
haven't exactly seen you know fizzing
bottles of champagne and lots of and
people sitting down to me a party is
people sitting well they had a few big
ones i mean he made it there have been
some big ones and they were vomiting and
fighting and breaking stuff yeah but i
don't go to parties ultimately it's not
about partying what it's about it's
about the fact that they were doing all
this breaking the laws they had made and
everybody else including the queen who
at phillips funeral had to sit on her
own that tragedy because she wanted to
obey the rules and the night before they
were partying in downing street till 4am
which i think is unforgivable well i do
too i think it's terrible but what are
you going to do i mean you're going to
get rid of boris who are you going to
bring in actually yes i do that i do
think when a prime minister breaks their
own rules and gets fined by the police
for it during a pandemic that's a
resignation event it used to be the old
days men would fall on their sword as a
matter of honor i don't think he knows
how to spell the word well who do you
suggest then is our next prime minister
somebody that can restore a bit of
integrity
somebody who's the somebody there's
always somebody every time you think
about it i don't think there's
irreplaceable you i
[Laughter]
wimbledon today has announced that
they're removing from the honors board
ms and miss before the names of previous
winners they want to make it gender
neutral
what are your thoughts
i think that's just the way everything's
going isn't it what about the men well
the men they they just call them you
know and djokovic i
it's just something that's been going on
and it's um something to me that you
know since emily pankhurst women have
fought fought for for equal rights so i
suppose this is them saying well this is
equal rights you know the media
right you can't be called a dame anymore
because it's two female titles well they
haven't said that to me what if they did
what if they came for your dame hood i
just threw it to them
you wouldn't you'd love being in danger
i love being a dame i mean
it's it's very flattering
in britain particularly because people
know what it is in the rest of the
country they don't know i mean in the
rest of the world in america a dame the
dame is you know something from damon
runyan it's what frank sinatra used to
call his girlfriend
yeah and uh of course in in europe like
in france percy sometimes says to
somebody it's dangerous
yeah they think this no i like i like it
of course but you know when you see a
very old-fashioned so when you see when
you see this debate where politicians
can't even say what a woman is now
wow
now
now we're not going to get on that
subject i do not a proof of people
saying that of course not because it's
just not fair it's not right
and
what is the answer to that
cancelled by the trans community thank
you very much but what is a woman what
is a woman me
[Laughter]
senior without her over there
there's plenty of us
but are you worried that in this trans
debate because i support trans rights
defenders so do i of course i just don't
like the attack on women's rights that
some of the activists are driving where
you have in sport this apparent
unfairness now going on i mean what do
you think when you see that
well i don't watch sport no but you know
what i'm talking about well i know what
you're talking about yes and i know what
you want me to say i don't
um
well of course it's uncensored
i think that a person should be
who they feel that they are and who they
but i do believe
i can't say this i can't say i can't no
i can't why you feel like you've got
because you make it i can't because i
don't want to get hate mail you see but
you've gone through your entire career
saying exactly what you always think no
i haven't yes you have no i read your
daughter
i've never i've never gotten into the uh
politics of biology okay no i haven't i
understand why people don't want to go
there yes i don't want to go there we're
talking about you what about madonna
who's auditioning for a new boy toy
you're kidding she is yeah you've just
made that up no she's apparently she
wants him to be hard-bodied what do you
mean hard-bodied and young oh that's
right we were with her son rocco yeah uh
last summer
and he said you know my mother says that
she will not sleep with anybody over the
age of 25.
i said no
you're kidding that's never been your
rule has it no i don't have rules
rules i'm very happily married with 20
years you didn't come to our anniversary
party i wasn't here as you know i was in
australia i know i know it's a fantastic
part and the great person as he always
is he's lurking in the wings like a
protective knife don't say that we're
lurking he's like
look at him no standing he just got he
saved me from the most embarrassing
wardrobe malfunction really party yes i
was talking to richard arnold your
friend yeah yeah and he was terribly
funny he made me laugh and the whole
zipper in the back of my dress went
and i'm sitting there with completely
gaping open and there's loads of
photographers was a big party
and i said to percy i don't know what to
do i know there was another dress i was
possibly going to wear because the theme
was red white or blue because it was a
jubilee party so i said you know the
white dresses that i left in the
wardrobe do you think you could bring it
so he went on luckily we don't live too
far away and i changed into another
dress and we were spared what would it
be perhaps a delightful incident i had
to sit there for at least half an hour i
had a huge feather bow which i kept on
putting on christopher biggins
around his neck he really liked that
and uh but it was fantastic
i've got to leave it there
but it was a wonderful interview it's
great to see that and i cannot wait to
see you in your jack on sunday at the
fact that he's going to be amazing yes
i'm going to see you there see you all
right i'll see you there okay yeah and i
thought i'm seeing you for dinner
tomorrow night
i'm a lucky guy new restaurant and
dinner with joan collins let me tell you
is hilarious lovely to see you great to
see you